how's it going everybody it's lauren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe as if there wasn't
already enough hype around spider-man 3
and all of the crazy and awesome reports
and rumors that come with it
things are getting even more exciting
now due to the fact that we should be
getting the first teaser for spider-man
3 in the mcu
really really soon a teaser for
spider-man 3 was promised to be coming
to us
by the end of the year and we think we
might have figured out when exactly
they're going to show it to us and i'll
break down when and everything you need
to know
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest spider-man 3 and mcu news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a black
widow funko pop from marvel's avengers
game
so if you were not aware not too long
ago executive marketing director at sony
pictures camilla pacheco
at expo sins annual convention made an
announcement
that spider-man 3 was in production
which of course has been
confirmed now and announced that we
would be getting our first look possibly
a full trailer or a teaser
before the end of this year she actually
specifically
said december 2020. now needless to say
things have been pretty exciting since
this announcement however we weren't
really sure
when or where this was going to happen
are they just going to release the
trailer randomly or are they going to do
it at some event
well in the past few days some things
have happened that lead us to believe
that we may
know when exactly they're going to
premiere the teaser cc xp
the comic-con experience in brazil
recently announced earlier this week
would be attending and would make their
presence known
they said that they will mark their
presence at ccxp worlds on december
4th and that's all they really said
except for the announcement that one of
their guests is going to be jeff
wydlow now it's a pretty big thing to
say that sony pictures is going to
mark their presence at the convention to
mark your presence means you have to do
something big and amazing
well the schedule for cc xp worlds was
recently revealed and for sony pictures
panel all they have listed
is monster hunter now there are fans
that are excited about this but that's
not really going to leave a mark
however what is listed for the 5 30 slot
says
locked panel meaning we don't know who
it's going to be or what they're going
to show
however speculation and slight rumors
say that this is actually going to be
sony now just so you're aware this is a
very big slot and last year it actually
went to marvel studios who are said to
not be there this year
but this slot is a very big deal for
example last year during this slot
marvel studios actually showed footage
from the eternals
they also showed black widow footage and
revealed a lot for the wanavision series
and the falcon and winter soldier series
as well it was by far the highlight of
cc xp last year and marvel definitely
made their mark
and right now it's expected but not
confirmed so don't get your hopes up
entirely
that this is going to be sony pictures
showing us that teaser they promised of
spider-man 3 and possibly some footage
of venom 2.
now this would be absolutely insane but
would definitely be a way for sony to
make their mark
monster hunter alone isn't going to do
it but showing footage of spider-man 3
definitely would another thing that kind
of points to our favor is that marvel
studios isn't attending
and they do have a lot that they could
show off but perhaps they're not
attending because the plan
all along was to show footage of
spider-man 3. this secret panel combined
with the fact that a sony executive told
us that we are going to be getting the
teaser
this month in december leads us to
believe that this
could be when we get the teaser now that
might not be the case but there is a lot
that suggests that this
is however if not we are promised it by
the end of the year so it still should
be this month
but in the meantime we can hope that it
comes tomorrow at cc
xp let me know how badly you would freak
out if we did in fact get our first look
at spider-man 3
tomorrow leave your thoughts down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news also on my other channel that i
have with my buddy chris we are giving
away a ps5 or at least the money for a
ps5 if we can't find one
so be sure to head over to cosmic
culture subscribe and comment on the
latest video so you can enter the
giveaway
don't forget to follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof